Thanks, Lauren. Let's move on to behavioral observation. What do we mean by
this? Remember that personality involves consistent and unique styles of
behaving, thinking, feeling, and our motivations. Now, it is the case that
other people cannot directly observe our thoughts. Internal feelings or
motivations. However, they can directly observe behavior. So having observers
make ratings of personality, based on behavior, is one technique used by
psychologist, to rate personality. This technique is popular when ratings of
personality, need to made be of people who can not easily describe their own
personality, such as young children. But it's not so simple as having a person
sit down and rate the personality of another. Why is that?